con el retiro de los demás de mil
soldados israelíes de los residentes del
campo de refugiados de llenín comienzan
a evaluar daños reconstruirlo destruido
y organizar los funerales de los
fallecidos sobre todos hombres y en su
mayoría jóvenes Desde la madrugada se
observó el regreso de aquellos que se
vieron forzados a escapar del campo
entre 3000 y 4.000 evacuados por la
media luna roja Palestina a casas de sus
familiares o refugios también se ha
restablecido el agua y la luz en algunos
puntos del campamento y se trabaja para
retirar escombros y reparar las calles
levantadas por el paso de los bulldozers
israelíes Mientras tanto el ministro de
defensa israelí Job galán destacó el
accionar de sus tropas ante el comité de
trabajo y bienestar del parlamento
israelí dijo que fueron destruidos
decenas de sitios de producción de
municiones explosivos y armas y advirtió
textualmente que los terroristas No
tendrán donde esconderse Así mismo
lamentó la muerte de un soldado durante
La retirada de las tropas anoche un
incidente que de acuerdo al portavoz del
ejército se está investigando Si fue por
disparos de milicianos palestinos o por
fuego israelí por otra parte en la
madrugada milicia Palestina desde casa
lanzaron cinco cohetes interceptados por
la defensa Antier israelí quien
represalia aviones israelíes
bombardearon un tercer subterráneo de
armas y un sitio de procesamiento de
elementos de cohetes usados por unidad
química de jamás y según medios
palestinos algunas casas de los
alrededores también fueron dañadas con
todo La pregunta es cuánto pasará hasta
la próxima operación en chelín ya que el
Primer Ministro israelí Benjamín de
taniajú prometió que la campaña no fue
algo de una sola vez sino el inicio de
incursiones regulares que se suman a las
redadas casi continuas que se han dado
desde hace más de un